police were determined to clear the
protesters from the government compound
the demonstrators were equipped with
umbrellas to protect them from the
pepper spray being used by security
forces at least 60 protesters were
arrested and several injured in the
clashes with police were taking our
umbrellas and plastic wraps away and
dousing us with high-strength pepper
spray many were injured they sprayed it
directly into the eyes at close range
it's painful painful effective
shamefully on delay the students demand
fully democratic local elections in 2017
last month Beijing said a government
committee would screen all candidates
for those elections protesters say
they're determined to push for real
change despite the violence yeah I don't
think you should run away just because
the police use pepper spray democracy is
something you have to fight for there
must be sacrifices yeah hey Sam laughs
another pro-democracy group says it's
planning a separate protest for the
coming days a blockade of Hong Kong's
financial district